what's going on guys this is rob and uh
we have a snowstorm going on here which
kind of sucks but phil lord and chris
miller the guys who wrote spider-man
into the spider-verse and are the ones
handling uh spider-man across the
spider-verse and
probably just any of the future into the
spider-verse movies because first one
won an academy award for best animated
films so i don't see why sony would take
them off the project they were doing an
interview recently
where they were talking about the idea
of toby andrew and uh and tom basically
appearing as as the various spider-man
in the film now of course they were a
little ambiguous in saying like
anything's possible in the multiverse uh
but here's one of the things you know
one of the things i've realized in doing
this right doing these kind of things is
that whenever something leaks from a
studio
it never actually leaks it's the studio
just kind of seemingly putting it out
there to see how people respond to it i
can't imagine there'd be anybody who
would be like i don't want to see toby
or andrew or tom in the spider-verse
film i just don't want to see that right
into the spider verse but having them in
there is a pretty big thing now there's
a few questions to ask here one
what capacity would they appear in the
film and two
what would be the significance of doing
that because i have a hard time
believing that sony would just be like
you know what people love tom holland
and toby and andrew they love seeing
them team up and spider-man no way home
so let's drop a few million dollars on
just having them appear in a movie right
i have a hard time believing that's the
decision that they would make there has
to be some kind of strategic reason as
to why they would be there now one of
the big theories that's been circulating
around a lot of you guys have been
talking about in the comments but one of
the big theories that's been circulating
around is that with the marvel cinematic
universe and sony basically preparing a
project with null the symbiote god that
he's going to be at least in some
capacity involved in this whole
spider-verse-centric event because it's
one of the things we talked about before
that when you talk about spider-man and
the spider-verse that all you've really
gotten here so far are basically a
series of origin films right spider-man
into the spider-verse was the origin of
miles morales and a few of the other
spider-man what what little we got and
then you throw in like tom holland
andrew garfield and toby maguire i
imagine their involvement in this movie
wouldn't be overly complex maybe it'd be
some kind of a post-credits scene or
maybe some kind of a cameo or something
along those lines we saw in the little i
guess preview trailer not really a
trailer per se but like sony basically
saying like this is the thing that's
coming uh that little video with regards
to miles morales and like miguel o'hara
spider-man 2099 meeting each other that
they were traveling through different
realities it'd be kind of interesting if
they ended up traveling through the
different realities of of tom and like
toby and andrew garfield this is
especially important because of the fact
that as far as we're aware with
spiderman no way home it was seemingly
the first time that andrew garfield and
and toby maguire learned
that like the multiverse exists and
there are other spiderman out there and
it's not just them i don't know of any
indication where they've ever learned
otherwise in the original spider-man
film there was nothing that introduced
the multiverse or anything like that it
was their standalone films on their
earth doing their things finding their
villains and like that was basically it
um this changed everything with
spider-man no way home and now what
would also be cool here and this is
something that i think would be really
really interesting i want to see them
invoke the idea of the web warriors and
i want to see tom and andrew and and uh
and toby basically be the members of it
or like the pioneers of it which i think
would be like a great homage to like no
way home because spider-man no way home
as you guys know is like the first major
spider-man film team-up film that we've
really gotten that was not animated
right spider-man of the spider-verse did
that beforehand but those of us who grew
up with the old toby films then went
into the andrew films and then we got
the tom films it was nostalgia feels and
so i loved the idea that in the
aftermath of everything that happened
with no way home that if some kind of an
event popped off and basically toby and
andrew basically ended up forming the
web warriors and then grab tom holland
in some form or fashion one it shows us
what tom holland is doing during the
events of doctor strange into the
multiverse of madness if he's not
necessarily being a part of the film
itself assuming that he's not out there
just being spider-man and that's
basically it uh the second thing it does
is it gives us more of his character
which i doubt any of us would dislike
and the third thing it does is it feeds
into the greater role of the
spider-verse inside the marvel cinematic
universe now for those of you guys who
don't know who the webb warriors are the
web warriors were basically like a
multiversal spider-man team uh it was
one of those things that initially came
out of the original spider-verse story
the term was just so popular it was
literally an off-handed remark that was
made or that was written by dan slott
for miles morales in the story right
where like literally there was one point
in spider-verse where spider-man where
peter parker sends miles into the
multiverse to recruit a whole bunch of
other spider-man and there's one point
where like they're coming they're
basically showing up during like this
final battle and peter asked him like
where are you at and he's like dude the
web warriors were on the way man people
loved it people absolutely loved it and
they actually turned it into a
relatively short-lived comic book series
but still like the concept is amazing so
us having the web warriors that were
founded by the spider-man that we love
so much seems great because one of the
things to notice about into the
spider-verse is that while you do have
spider-ham and you do have spider-man
noir and you've got spider-gwen and
those characters they're not a de facto
multiversal team per se they're just
some spider-man who teamed up and did
some stuff but there's not really any
basis behind their existence outside of
whatever the plot demanded there really
isn't anything there that's uniting them
in terms of like some off-screen
multiversal threat that requires them to
work together but it would be pretty
interesting here if in the aftermath of
what happened with snowy home that once
toby maguire went back given his
scientific prowess then he basically
started experimenting because one of the
things that i'm kind of curious about
this in terms of where you guys stand
who do you think is smarter tom holland
is obviously i mean he seemed to have a
legitimate chance to get into mit the
marvel cinematic universe something that
i noticed they very much downplayed the
intelligence of peter parker like it's
something they didn't really focus on
all that much but in terms of toby and
in terms of andrew it was very much a
part of their characters so which of
those three do you think is the greater
scientific genius right like tony
maguire andrew garfield or tom holland i
feel like people are going to say tom
only because of the time he spent with
iron man but regardless it would be very
very interesting if in the aftermath of
that toby mcguire went back to the
drawing board and basically started
looking at the idea of like the
multiverse like let's explore this
multiversal thing he became what we
would call his own universe's reed
richards to a degree not nearly as
intelligent but curious about life
beyond his own universe maybe he
stumbles across the idea of null or
maybe he's the one that realizes that
other spider-man from across the
multiverse are being killed because
remember in the original spider-verse
event it wasn't like when dr octopus
took over the body of peter parker and
became the superior spider-man it wasn't
like some external force out there
started chasing him down and then he
realized oh my god somebody's coming
after me he basically had been
transported to the future to the marvel
2099 universe he was trying to get back
home to his own universe ended up in an
alternate reality and found the version
of spider-man and that universe was dead
and whenever he was trying to get back
home he was accidentally being
transported to other universes aside
from the main novel universe but each
one of these universes he went to he
found the spider-man and spider-woman
had been killed and they had all been
killed in the same way by what looked to
be the same weapon which indicated a
person is traveling across the
multiverse killing spiderman from there
it was just simply investigating and
then he realized what was going on and
that's when you saw it coming together
of the spiderman from across the
multiverse so it's not like it has to be
some overly complicated thing right that
literally toby's like i mean let's just
see what's out there like if for no
other reason to satisfy my curiosity
like hey mj i know i didn't make it to
your play it's because i was just kind
of investigating the multiverse and
seeing what was going on and what he
noticed is that different spider-man
from across the multiverse were being
killed and this basically leads to him
grabbing andrew garfield because they've
teamed up right he's spider-man 3 he
needs a little bit of a confidence boost
right spider-man 3 you know and then you
have you have them reaching out to tom
holland and then tom holland comes on
board and it's like somebody's killing
spider-man from across the multiverse
we've teamed up before let's team up
again somewhere along the way they run
into miguel o'hara or maybe miles
morales and they're like hey cool more
people for the ride and then suddenly
you got a spider-man team and they're
all investigating why it is that
spider-man are being killed across the
multiverse or spider-man are being
corrupted by venom simians which are
being used by no the symbiote god
whatever happens to fit the plot of the
movie that they're trying to work with
but let me know what you guys think
right i think it's a cool idea i think
it's a cool concept right having the
different spider-man working together in
the team itself largely being founded by
tobey maguire he was the original
spider-man in terms of the movies that
we all pretty much care about anyway i
guess soup high-demand could kind of be
the original live-action one if you want
to go that way but but tony mcguire as
far as we're concerned is like the
original spider-man movie right the one
that we all pretty much started out with
and so because of that he'd be a great
person to choose for the founding of the
team he grabs andrew he grabs tom they
end up with a couple other people and
then what do you know you got the web
warriors fighting some multiversal
threat out there with a giant spider-man
team up so let me know what you guys
think down in the comments section thank
you all for watching and i will catch
you all later
peace